الاحتلال لم يترك شيء الا وقصفه ودمره هنا
في شمال قطاع غزه حتى شبكات الاتصالات
والانترنت لم تسلم من قصف الاحتلال مما
ادى الى معاناه المواطنين في محاوله
الحصول على نقطه اتصال او نقطه انترنت
والتواصل مع عائلاتهم في جنوب قطاع غزه
وخارج ايضا قطاع غزه هنا بعض العائلات
تحاول الحصول على نقطه اتصال من اجل
الاطمئنان على عائلاتهم في خارج قطاع غزه
وفي جنوب قطاع غزه لكن الاحتلال هنا يفرض
قيود ويمنع هذه الاتصالات ويمنع ايضا
الانترنت حتى هذه اللحظه هنا على قطاع غزه
عاوزين نتواصل مع ابنائنا برا بالخارج
الكل جلجل علينا بنا نطمئن عليهم ويطمئنوا
علينا احنا في وضع صعب ماساوي عمره ما حصل
منذ تكم نكبه ال 48 ما ما صار زي ه النكبه
هذه تعتبر مليون نكبه هذه بدي اتواصل مع
اخوتي بره اولاد اخويا بدي اطمئن عليهم
يطمئنوا علي مش قادرين نتواصل معهم والله
صعب كثير بلف كل يوم بالساعتين عشان نقدر
نوصل لنقطه اتصال ولما نوصل بلاقي على
الفاضي يعني انا الليي تقريبا اكثر من شهر
ونص مش قادره اتواصل مع ولا حدا من اهلي
بالجنوب وما بعرفش هم وين وكل في يعني بس
بسمع اخبار من مكان لمكان لكن اني اتاكد
او اطمن او اعرف لسه عايشين مستشهدين مش
قادره بسبب صعوبه الاتصال لا نت ولا اتصال
الارسال طبعا بالمره سيء جدا والنت برضه
على الفاضل سيء
جدا صعب جدا انك تلاقي الانترنت يعني بقدر
نقول حرب ثانيه اللي هو صعب التواصل مع
الاهل وخاصه انه اهلي انا في الخارج في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وصعب اننا
نتواصل معهم بعد عناء او تعب وطبعا النت
للاسف ميت على الاخر وحتى الاتصال
والتواصل معده تقريبا من ع ايام و 15 يوم
يا دوب ما قدرت حتى والدي من شهرين ما
كلمتوش واخوي لاخوي الاصغر مني اللي برا
كلمته تقريبا قبل 10 ايام و 15 يوم طبعا
معاناه معاناه بكل ما تحمل الكلمه من
معاناه هذه حرب ثانيه غير الحرب اللي احنا
قاعدين بنعاني والدمار وكل هذا اللي احنا
بنشوفه عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي صعب
جدا جدا عبر قناه الجزيره وحتلاقي فيديو
اللي باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى كنا بخير
وبنسلم عليكم وبسلم على الوالد وبتقول له
هذا قدر الله وهذا قدرنا على هذه
الارض المعاناه هنا تلاحق الاهالي في كل
مكان حتى في التواصل مع عائلاتهم في جنوب
قطاع غزه وخارج قطاع غزه نتيجه القصف
المتواصل لنقاط الاتصال وانقطاع كامل
للاتصالات هنا في شمال القطاع انس الشريف
الجزيره شمال غزه